I'm caldo Chad I'm a singer-songwriter
from Montreal and I composed the music
for child of light Carla P hat rings
that sense of intimacy there's also a
youthfulness in the music you know she
plays the piano my experience with you
basalt was great i was there from the
beginning so I remember when they asked
you to do it they didn't have like that
much material for me to work with so I
got to have this complete freedom and
then when I first saw the images I was
thrown away I thought it was wonderful I
was so beautifully made there's so much
death to it all and I really felt that I
could work with that for me that music
was there to create that sense of
intimacy of nostalgia when we're
exploring but also that sense of energy
that we have when we're doing fights or
best fights at first it was supposed to
be something really small just like a
piano and guitar and maybe a cello and
it was kind of a challenge because
whenever you get into a boss I'd it gets
so much more intense and we actually had
to commission a whole Orchestra to do
the boss spice
three epic big and apparatus
I remember seeing for the first time the
music on the images and I kind of tear
it up a little bit because it's just so
wonderful to see something come to life
like that
I wanted to sound to be really organic
and magical at the same time so it was
it was quite a challenge to get those
two mixed together for our hours I
didn't want the Foley just to be the
only thing that would make this hound
you know just cloth and and gear so for
the wings we tried so many things it was
never working really at the end try the
fully artist suggested we use a flower
and it actually works really good it
makes some really believable wings news
we also work with Saudi LA to really
help enhance the sense of theatricality
in our game my first impression of this
project was wow this looks wonderful
it's beautifully designed I think it's a
breath of fresh air in the world with
most video games are based on muscular
demonstrations graphics and power
working with since la brings us their
world-class experience in realization
and also in terms of design they're used
to create those extravagant costume
those exotic world and for me that was a
perfect match with child of light they
would show me things they would ask for
my opinion and we were just debate and
discuss how some of these things could
be improved or transformed I'm not a
video game designer and I think that's
what they specifically wanted for me was
the stage direction point of view I was
sort of brought back to my childhood
into this sort of fairytale world that
was very beautiful very fulfilling and
to be able to play something that
reminds me of these fairytales was truly
great
the writing and child of light is
entirely in rhyme and so I had to really
treat almost every stanza as a puzzle